I’m standing on Blackheath Common in south-east
London. But if I wanted to tell someone my exact
location, how would I describe it? I could say
I was 500 metres south of Greenwich Observatory,
but that would only be useful to people who
know where the observatory is. I could use
the address of the nearest building, but that’s
several hundred metres away, so that wouldn’t be
very accurate. One reliable way to describe
where I am is to use a pair of co-ordinates.
Co-ordinates are numbers that specify a
location on the earth’s surface relative
to an agreed reference point. There are
lots of different co-ordinate systems,
but probably the best known is the
geographic co-ordinate system, which
uses latitude and longitude. That’s the system
underlying every GPS-enabled device you own.
Latitude is a measure of how far north
or south of the equator a point is,
while longitude is a measure of
how far east or west a point is,
relative to an imaginary line drawn through the
Greenwich Observatory, which is just over there.
At the moment I’m standing exactly on
that line, so my longitude is zero.
The geographic co-ordinate system is
used in lots of applications. But one
difficulty with latitude and longitude is
that they are usually measured in degrees.
A latitude of zero means a location
on the equator, while a latitude of
plus ninety degrees means a location at the north
pole. Right now I’m standing at fifty-one degrees
north of the equator. But degrees aren’t very
useful for measuring everyday distances – it’s
not very informative to say that the nearest
railway station is 0.01 degrees walk from here.
Because degrees of latitude and longitude
aren’t easy to work with, it’s often easier
to use a different type of coordinate system when
making maps. These are called projected coordinate
systems, and they work by specifying a location
relative to a well-defined starting point.
There are lots of different projected coordinate
systems that cover different parts of the Earth’s
surface. For example, for locations in London
we can use the British National Grid system.
This specifies locations based on how
many metres east and north they are from
a specific point in the Atlantic Ocean
off the coast of Cornwall. Because the
British National Grid measures distances
in metres, it is easier to work with.
We will use co-ordinates specified in lots
of projected co-ordinate systems during this
course. But there is one draw-back
of projected co-ordinate systems:
the people who design them have to deal with
the fact that maps are flat but the surface of
the earth is curved. We don’t need to go into
the mathematical details of how this is done,
but it’s important to know that there is simply
no way to accurately represent a curved surface
on a flat map without some distortion. There
are lots of different ways to manage this
problem. Which solution is best depends on the
circumstances, so people designing projected
co-ordinate systems for different parts of
the globe will make different decisions.
That has two consequences for us as map makers.
Firstly, we must know which co-ordinate system
a particular dataset uses. Knowing a pair of
co-ordinates is useless unless we also know
the co-ordinate system. Most spatial datasets have
this information embedded in them, but if not then
it’s vital that you find out what co-ordinate
system the data uses. One way to do that is to
ask whoever provided the data what co-ordinate
system they used. The second important point is
that projected co-ordinate systems only work for
the part of the globe that they were designed for.
If you use the wrong co-ordinate system, or
use a co-ordinate system for a different part
of the world, it’s quite likely that
your map will have errors in it or
some of the features will look distorted.
For example, you probably recognise this
outline of the UK. But if you told a computer
to transform that outline using a co-ordinate
system designed to make maps of Canada,
you’ll see the outline becomes deformed.
Dealing with co-ordinates can seem complicated,
but they allow us to accurately identify locations
on the earth’s surface. That’s a crucial
step in being able to do useful things with
spatial data – we will learn about many of
those things during the rest of the course.
In summary:
We use co-ordinates to describe
locations on the Earth’s surface
Different projected co-ordinate systems
are used for different parts of the globe
It is vital that we know which co-ordinate
system a particular dataset uses